[Musica]
e poi così via così via la conoscete no
ok Alla Turca sapete chi l'ha composta
proprio lui proprio Mozart Ecco
Mozart era Quel genio Quel genio
descritto come genio Quel genio che ci
ha causato la più grande sindrome di
impotenza che potessimo mai raggiungere
Anche perché da quando siamo bambini che
ci raccontano che Mozart ha 8 anni ha
composto la sua prima sinfonia k16 Ecco
io non ho 8 anni mi toglievo le caccole
e cercavo di sentirne il gusto quindi ho
sempre avuto un attimo di problemi con
Mozart
qua siamo in questo Ted siamo a parlare
di esopianeti di New Era vi chiederete
quindi che cosa c'entra un autore del
Settecento con la New Era c'è un
collegamento e quel collegamento è la
musica trap
la musica Trap Avete presente il tratto
distintivo della musica trap e non sto
parlando di insultare la mamma del tuo
collega intendo l'autotune Ecco
l'autotune è quello strumento
eccezionale geniale che viene utilizzato
in continuazione da qualsiasi musicista
esecutore anche i più precisi per
intonare quelle piccole stonature che ci
possono essere sia durante un esibizione
live che durante una registrazione
Ecco la musica è un è Un collante è Un
collante tra un passato che tutti noi
pensiamo non essere influente rispetto
al presente e un presente in costante
evoluzione questo passato che pensiamo
non essere nulla in realtà E la cosa più
fondamentale per il nostro presente e di
conseguenza per il nostro futuro e ve lo
spiego dicendovi che Mozart
faceva trap
non nel senso che insultava la mamma dei
suoi colleghi Ma nel senso che
utilizzava l'autotune vi spiego Avete
presente
therehol Rachi e cocktail
Non è vero che ce l'hai presente non
fare Sì the holder hacker e io non
capisco un HD tedesco lo abbrevio der
Hall rack non è altro che l'aria della
Regina della notte nel flauto magico di
Mozart quell'opera tutta musicata da
Mozart e ve la faccio sentire è quella
che fa la conoscete di sicuro
Avete presente no quell'opera che va
molto su arriva a un fa un fatissimo
ecco quando si scrive un'opera
utilizzare una nota così alta
tendenzialmente serve a diverse cose può
servire a descrivere un momento di gioia
pazzesco Come descrivere un momento di
rabbia Ecco io di tedesco non capisco
un'acca e dato che anche solo ambulanza
in tedesco si dice cancro vagin Per
quanto mi riguarda The Hole rachie
cocktail potrebbe voler dire
coloratissime farfalle volano
in realtà vuol dire la vendetta
dell'inferno Ribolle dentro il mio cuore
capite che c'è un attimo di rabbia in
particolare in questo momento dell'Opera
Noi abbiamo la regina della notte astri
fiammante che sta consegnando un pugnale
a sua figlia Dicendole di andare ad
uccidere il suo peggior nemico ovvero
sarastro
e visto che la regina della notte oltre
che è arrabbiata e anche un po' stronza
le dice se saràstro non proverà le pene
dell'inferno per mano tua
maledetta Sì per sempre non sarai più
mia figlia
il prototipo della mamma ideale ecco per
fare la mamma ideale in quest'opera non
poteva bastare un Soprano qualsiasi e
non poteva bastare un'esecuzione
qualsiasi e quindi Mozart ha scritto la
nota più alta mai scritta per voce umana
e non tutti i Soprani più bravi
riuscivano arrivare in modo preciso a
quella nota così alta Quindi bisognava
adottare uno stratagemma adesso
ascoltiamo insieme quei pochi secondi
del della Regina della notte del Flauto
magico e poi vi spiego una cosa
[Musica]
sentite Come arriva
si carica
[Musica]
Ecco qua perfetto avete sentito quanto
va in alto sembra quasi che quando si
arriva a quelle note la base
dell'orchestra smette di suonare non si
faccia più sentire lasci spazio alla
voce Ecco non è così ci sono due piccoli
flautini un po' timidi dietro
l'orchestra che non conosce nessuno che
non alzano la mano non si fanno vedere
che fanno rispettivamente
e lo fanno insieme coordinati sembrano
non esistere ma ci sono adesso
riascoltiamo un'altra volta questo
momento di quest'area e guardate il mio
dito Io vi indicherò il suono di questi
Flauti E poi vi spiego
stanno arrivando
[Musica]
Eh ok
Avete sentito li avete sentiti quei due
flauti non li senti mai nessuno sembra
non esistere sembra non esserci se
qualcuno non ve lo fa notare non ci sono
Se non andate a leggere lo spartito non
ci sono ed esattamente come l'autotune
non hanno mai sovrastato la voce non
hanno mai coperta per coprire le
imperfezioni Ma hanno fatto sì che il
nostro orecchio venisse ingannato dalla
sostegno armonico e non percepisse
l'eventuale imperfezione del soprano e
geniale è un inganno Mozart ci ha
ingannato
in giro non ce ne siamo mai accorti ma
Mozart Con questo ci ha preso in giro
Ecco se adesso noi paragoniamo il
presente al pianeta che conosciamo e il
futuro ha un eso pianeta
Chissà quante cose Noi stiamo applicando
adesso nel mondo che conosciamo come
piccoli stratagemmi e che in realtà in
futuro diventeranno magari un programma
per correggere la voce magari
diventeranno un metaverso magari
diventeranno chissà che cosa si
evolveranno di stratagemmi del genere La
musica è piena ci sono sostegni armonici
ci sono ritmi timbri silenzi i silenzi
i silenzi nella musica silenzio
fondamentale è un po' come nella vita
anche la felicità più bella senza la
tristezza diventa noiosa Ecco il
silenzio nella musica è fondamentale ed
è sempre quella cosa per cui i
professori cercano di inculcarlo nella
testa degli alunni ma non ci riescono
mai e c'era un personaggio della storia
della musica che si è concentrato
tantissimo sul silenzio e ha provato a
spiegarlo quel personaggio era John Cage
che non è l'attore di Ghost Rider quello
è Nicolas Cage John Cage era fuori come
un balcone e ha scritto 4:33
adesso sembra un nome un po' strano vi
faccio vedere lo spartito questo qui è
lo spartito di 4.33 Ecco mi rendo conto
che visto così sembra di intrattenimento
come un cane con la tosse e soprattutto
viene scritto per qualsiasi strumento o
qualsiasi combinazione di strumento
chiunque può suonare 4.33 e vedete che
dopo il primo atto c'è scritto
perché sì
4.33 sono 4 minuti e 33 secondi di
silenzio
giuro ci sono ci sono video su YouTube
potete trovarli di pianisti che arrivano
al pianoforte si siedono e stanno fermi
per 4 minuti e 33 direttore d'orchestra
che arrivano
e stanno fermi per 4 minuti e 33
con questo John Cage voleva raccontare
che la musica e anche silenzio il
silenzio in sé esso stesso suonare
quando uno strumento è zitto Sta
suonando il silenzio è incredibile no
ecco adesso io vi risparmierò la mia
personalissima complete esecuzione della
versione integrale di 4 minuti e 33 ma
penso di avervi fatto passare il
messaggio La musica è orizzontale la
musica non conosce una lingua non ha un
idioma corretto non ha dei muri dei
Confini dei vincoli chiunque può fruire
della musica in mille modi diversi può
ascoltarla in cuffia può ascoltarla
riprodotta da un pianoforte può
ascoltare con delle casse può ascoltare
in un nuovo metaverso la musica e
duttile si adatta al tempo si adatta al
passare al nuovo pianeta la musica si
adatta non era la musica e la New Era
quando vi dico che la musica è inutile
adesso vi faccio un esempio così la
facciamo più facile Avete presente che
sarà sarà
Avete presente anche Generale di De
Gregori Generale dietro alla collina ci
sta la notte quella lì Ecco sembrano due
brani che non c'entrano niente tra di
loro per farvi capire quanto la musica
sia duttile Adesso vi suono che sarà
sarà per farvi sentire generale ci provo
[Musica]
questo è quando vi dico la musica e
duttile e quando vi dico che la musica
si abbraccia avete sentito una cosa che
diventa un'altra che diventa un'altra
che è diventato poi un altro brano
ancora una cosa che si trasforma
improvvisando non era studiato non era
preparato la musica si si si è
malleabile la musica non guarda in
faccia ai traguardi
un musicista che sente la musica dentro
non lo fa per vincere qualcosa perché se
non vince niente continua a fare musica
per consolarsi se vince qualcosa non si
ferma un musicista non fa musica per
vincere il Festival di Sanremo ma vince
il Festival di Sanremo Perché fa musica
che è diverso la musica
non ha età non guarda in faccia il sesso
alla politica le ideologie la musica e
partecipazione la musica e libertà La
musica è antirazzista
Ecco io non so niente di esopianeti di
New Era non ne capisco niente ma una
cosa che so è che la musica c'è sempre
stata e sempre ci sarà evolvendosi
insieme al futuro quindi da adesso in
poi per favore Quando scrivete musica
scrivetelo con la m maiuscola Grazie
[Applauso]